[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the phantom menace to society that's
here to break down episode 15 of the bad
batch
i really can't believe that it's been
that long but we're in the end game now
and the penultimate entry has a lot of
easter eggs hidden details and things
you missed that hint towards what's
going to be happening in the finale
obviously there's full spoilers for the
series in this video so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then go
look at some other other breakdowns yes
it's look it's been 15 weeks but if
you've been with us the whole time
then smash that thumbs up button and
make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss next week we're
gonna be fun and without the way thank
you for clicking this yeah
let's get into the bad batch now last
week saw project war mantle come into
full effect
this was an operation carried out by the
imperials that slowly shifted their army
away from relying on clones
and instead the empire began relying on
enlisted citizens
yesterday disney announced that we would
be getting a second season of the show
and this episode leaves it so that the
clones are pretty much all but destroyed
i'm not sure exactly who wrote this on
one of my videos but shout out to the
commenter who did
and they said they think they'll be a
big order 66 but for the clone troopers
so give yourself a pat on the back if
that was you and just do it
you know what if it wasn't you just give
yourself a pat on the back anyway you
deserve it
also kick me in the face as i missed
scorching last week's episode after
banging on about how good republic
commando was for about 20 minutes
now the episode itself centered around
the batch rescuing gregor for captain
rex
and though the operation almost went off
without a hitch hunter was captured at
the end and forced to come face to face
with
crosshair that should have you fully
caught up now and it leads instantly
into this new episode
now return to kamino starts off with the
imperial forces traveling through
hyperspace
this framing device has been how a
number of episodes have opened with the
batch
but its usage here shows the dark path
that hunter is on
crosshair takes hunter's combs device
which is based on the newer model that
we saw in a new hope
the original one used in the prequel
trilogy was actually a repurposed
women's racer
and this switch up shows how the tech
will come to be in the original trilogy
hunter says they'll know it's a trap but
as crosshair rightly states
they'll come for him because of their
loyalty camino is of course an important
location
as it's not only where they were created
but potentially it's also the place that
they could die
after the cadbane episode omega stated
that going back there was her greatest
fear
and hunter promised that she'd never
have to however due to his capture
she must return and this very much plays
into the notion of traveling into the
belly of the beast
which pulls from the hero's journey
story archetype first popularized by
joseph campbell
this involves a hero being plucked from
their home getting a mentor and then
traveling into a location
that transforms them it's something
that's been used in the majority of star
wars properties
and that death of a mentor bit could
spell doom for hunter if they stick to
this arc
we return to ord mantel and learn that
gregor has been dropped off with sid
so i'm guessing that unless he pops up
in season two that last week's episode
will be the final time we see him before
rebels
might also show up in the finale but you
never know now shout outs to simon a
birman
on you guessed it twitter for pointing
out that gunky is back after his
sacrifice last week
but that he's now being used to rest a
toolbox on you bloody idiot gunky
you're useless now due to last week's
confrontation
the ship is badly damaged but they fix
it up and track hunter to camino
which we can now see is completely
overrun by imperials
the music also pulls directly from the
kamino score used in attack of the
clones
and i have to say i love this setting
due to the weather conditions
there's such a darkness to the planet
but there's also some contrast to this
when we pass into the corridors and see
the beaming bright lights
for me it's one of the coolest settings
in the star wars saga
and come the end of the episode i was a
bit emotional
now we learned that enlisted citizens
are fully overrunning the clones and
this shift was seen in the introduction
of tk numbers
over the cc ones we can also see
stormtrooper uniforms which
look like they're based on the original
designs by ralph macquarie
rampart greets them and discusses ryloth
and omega brings up the location's name
which is to poker city
she knows of a secret landing pad and as
we theorize the location is destroyed at
the end of the entry
during the cad bane episode there was of
course a rundown counterpart to this
which existed in the clouds
we learned that the operation there had
been destroyed due to a critical core
issue for that there was an escape pod
which might be showing up next week
the atmosphere is so tense and i'm
surprised that nobody said they didn't
have a bad feeling about this
the bats use a hidden platform that
requires you to be close to
it and they sneak inside through a tube
system located beneath the city
this reminded me a lot of the scenes in
empire and the tunnel i travel down
looks a lot like the one that luke falls
into after facing off against his father
there's also flashes of the gungan city
here from naboo and it's such a cool
moment that perfectly builds tension
towards what's to come
they arrive in nala cey's lab which is
hidden from the majority of those
into poke city we learn that this is
where they develop the deviant clones
that all have certain mutations put in
place
in order to improve them last week we
theorized that knowledge would end up
going to work on cloning the emperor
as well as snoke and i think this scene
which discusses their expertise
just about confirms it the major
experiments are carried out there
and omega says that she was there when
the batch were created and i took this
as meaning that she's actually older
than they are
now you could take it that she means she
was just part of this room too but i
kind of lean more into the former theory
as
that's way more interesting of a twist
me and simon simon the old boy we were
talking about this
and decided that if she looked over them
growing in the tanks
then it makes sense why she was so
desperate to meet them in the first
episode
the full system has been wiped out and
we see that az34586
69 is still there who you might
recognize from the first episode
yes i'm very immature we learned that he
ended up hiding after the tk troopers
ushered everyone there on to transports
and that the only clone left is
crosshair they actually use his original
designation of ct
9904 which shows that he's now viewed as
a number
rather than as an individual jumping me
grave as fast would yeah taking me
bloody uniform
and at this point the clones are now in
the minority rather than being the
majority
the batch girl looking for crosshair and
omega is told to wait behind
and contact rex if things go south he of
course will no doubt be popping up for
the finale
and the character definitely owes them
one she does take a different strategy
but i think they're clearly setting up
his return
and that he will potentially show up
next week maybe even with ahsoka
they shoot up into the training arena
which was of course where they
demonstrated their skills in the first
episode
it's a trap though and crosshair has
lured them there
omega ends up launching the dark
troopers which were used for training
and you might remember these soldiers as
being part of moth gideon's forces in
the mandalorian
hunter rightly tells crosshair that the
imperials are facing out the clones
and we get a big theory about him
confirmed we've often discussed in
videos how
we believe that his chip didn't really
work and that it malfunctioned
we said that crosshairs simply chose to
be part of the imperials because that's
what his values align with
and we discover that his chip was
removed a long time ago
the burn marks on his head hit the score
and it's nice to have this
basically hiding in plain sight for a
lot of the season now he believed that
the batch stood for the order that the
empire would bring
and that that is what they were fighting
for the whole time crosshair feels
betrayed because those he was loyal to
left him behind
and nazi aligned with the imperials as
they were what made him feel useful
he's one of the best soldiers in the
galaxy right now and he gives them the
choice to either join the imps as his
brothers
or to die crosshair murders the rest of
the elite squad in an amazing hole in
one
and omega is caught by the final member
crosshair orders her to be sent off
world
however az arrives and saves her now
there are theories that this elite squad
member
is actually iden versio but the timeline
doesn't really match up
as she would be a child at this point
however it is possible that it's her
mother z
hey who did serve for the empire i know
there's other characters it could be too
so if you have any ideas then let me
know below who you think it is
now once the droids ambush everyone
crosshair ends up fighting alongside his
brothers
and the star destroyers end up raining
fire on the location
we learn from rampart that the cloning
tech is now under imperial control
and tarkin says he may fire when ready
which the character of course repeated
during the death star's attack on
alderaan
as always the batch are stuck in
alderaan places
and they're completely unaware of what's
about to happen
hunter holds a gun to his brother and
tells him to forget the empire
but crosshair refuses and this is when
he reveals the truth about the chip
hunter ends up stunning them and they
try to escape but that plan is very
short-lived
now it's crazy watching the camino
facility which was so
full of life abandoned and the place is
absolutely decimated from the sky
in one of the most impactful moments in
the series thus far
we don't know if the batch survive and
leads to one of the darkest endings thus
far
we don't get any music in the credits
and it left me desperate to find out
what happens in the finale
now obviously that yeah they will
survive and i think they'll end up
teaming up with crosshair in order to
escape
they might even reach out to rex to come
save them or
use the escape pod that we know exists
on the platforms
the empire have just betrayed crosshair
and shown what they're really like
and though he thought he was valued as
we know from our jobs
no company will ever love you as much as
you love it
just go self-employed yeah go
self-employed like the batch
you'll thank me later now overall very
very solid entry that does its job in
just knocking all the dominoes down and
getting me really excited for what's
going to come next week
i will be back but until then obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know we're also running a competition
right now and giving away three mcu box
sets on the 30th of august
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment with
your thoughts on the entry
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now
so message me on twitter heavy spoilers
if that's you if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the venom trailer which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over the entire thing from top to
bottom so it's definitely worth checking
out
if you want to know more about that
movie that other way thank you for
sending you this video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care
peace